WEDNESDAY MARCH SIXTH.
MEETING OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
TO ORDER MADAM SECRETARY WILL
YOU CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
SENATORS BATES.
THE MINING ROCK.
ROB HERE WELL ROUNDED WILK HERE
ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND I KNOW THAT --
MISTER MINING IS ON HIS WAY WE
HAD A I JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE THAT
YOUR ROD POSSIBLY UNLESS SOMEONE
PULLS AN ITEM --
ON NUMBER TWO BILL REFERRALS
THREE JOINT COMMITTEES.
SELECT COMMITTEES ITEM FOUR AND
FIVE AND I THINK WE CAN DO FLORA
KNOWLEDGE MEN'S. SIX THROUGH
[inaudible]
EIGHT SO.
WONDERFUL LET ME MAKE SURE.
AND MAKE SURE YOU'RE OKAY WITH
THAT UNLESS YOU WANNA.
FULL ANYONE OKAY SO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON TO FOR A CONSENT
CALENDAR OF ITEMS TWO THROUGH.
EIGHT MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS FAITH [inaudible]
ROCK.
ROUGH I WILL.
WILK AYE ATKINS AYE.
AND WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
SO THAT MISTER MINING CAN ADD ON
WHEN HE GETS HERE.
THANK YOU --
AND WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE TO
THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES.
AND LET ME INVITE KEY LEE BOSS
FOR THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
WELCOME.
AND I THINK WHAT WE CAN DO I MS
FOSLER IF YOU WANT TO INTRODUCE
ANYONE THIS WITH YOU TODAY MAKE
YOUR OPENING COMMENTS AND THEN
WE'LL GET RIGHT INTO IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU PRESIDENT
PRO TEM AND AT THE END SENATORS
YEAH IT'S REALLY A GREAT HONOR
THAT I SAID BEFORE YOU TODAY AT
THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE AND I
WANT TO FIRST THANK.
GOVERNOR A NEWSOM FOR THE
ABSOLUTE PRIVILEGE TO HAVE TAKEN
THIS ROLE AND SOMEONE START
THERE.
I'M HERE BECAUSE OF MANY PEOPLE
BOTH PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY AND I WANT TO
FIRST THANK MY FAMILY AND I AM
JOINED BY MY HUSBAND MITCHELL
BOSS THERE TODAY.
M. THEY HE AND MY TWO DAUGHTERS
ALICE SANDRA AND HENRIETTA THEY
THEY REALLY GROUNDS ME AND
SUPPORT ME IN EVERY WAY EVERY
DAY AND SOME VERY GRATEFUL TO
THEM.
I ALSO WANT TO JUST QUICKLY
THANK MY PARENTS MARLENE AND
CHARLIE HER WATCHING FROM OUR
SMALL FAMILY FARM WHERE I GREW
UP.
AND THEY TAUGHT ME THE EARLY ON
WORK AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL TO
THAT FOR FOR THAT AND I'M ALSO
VERY GRATEFUL FOR MY IN LAWS BOB
AND SALLY BECAUSE THEY'RE
THEY'RE A HUGE PART.
OF OUR SUPPORT SYSTEM I'M EACH
AND EVERY DAY AND HELP US TO
RAISE OUR TWO DAUGHTERS --
BUT I ALSO WANNA --
THANK AT THE ENTIRE IT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT THE
WORK PRODUCT OF MY OFFICE ARE
MADE POSSIBLE ONLY BY ALL OF
THEIR COLLECTIVE EFFORTS AND
HARD WORK AND SO I'M VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF ALL OF THEM.
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK HAVE A
SPECIAL THANKS --
TO MICHAEL COHEN MY PREDECESSOR
WHO'S HERE TODAY I'M JUST SO
MUCH OF A VALUE IN AND WONDERFUL
WORKING WITH HIM MY ENTIRE
CAREER --
I'VE HAD MANY HELPING HANDS
ALONG THE WAY INCLUDING MANY
THAT ARE MANY THAT I MET HERE IN
THE SENATE AND I WANT TO GIVE
SPECIAL RECOGNITION TO BOTH
NINETY SABLE HOUSE IN DIANNE
CUMMINS. FOR IN THE FRONT ROW
HERE TODAY WITH ME AND THEY'VE
JUST BEEN A HUGE SUPPORT.
AND THEIR GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT
IS REALLY HUMBLED ME AND I SO
APPRECIATIVE OF THEM.
I'M AS THE DRECTOR OF FINANCE
IT'S MY RESPONSIBILITY TO WORK
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
A TO MAINTAIN THE STATE'S FISCAL
HEALTH AND IT'S MY GOAL OF A
BILL THAT RESPONSIBILITY WHILE
ALSO MAKING INVESTMENTS.
THAT IMPROVE AFFORDABILITY AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
I'VE LEARNED OVER THE YEARS THE
WORKING ON THE STATE BUDGET THAT
MAINTAINING.
THE FISCAL STABILITY IS AN
ONGOING CHALLENGE --
BUT IT IS ALSO A NECESSARY.
FOUNDATION THAT MUST BE
MAINTAINS.
AT FOR EXPANDINGPROGRAMS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
EACH OF YOU --
AS WE MAINTAIN THE STATE'S A
STRNG FISCAL FOUNDATION THAT WE
HAVE TODAY SO AT AT WITHOUT I
JUST LIKE --
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE FROM.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
BEFORE WE GET STARTED I WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT MISTER MINING
HAS JOINED US.
AND I'M GIVE YOU A CHECK A
SECOND TO CATCH YOUR BREATH WE
DID A CONSENT CALENDAR.
PERFECT MADAM SECRETARY.
ITEMS TWO THROUGH EIGHT SENATOR
MONNING [inaudible]
MODERN I THANK YOU SO MUCH ARE
SO WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
THAT PASSED UNANIMOUSLY.
AND NOW -- I
AM HAPPY TO START MISTER ROSS
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO KICK
US OFF.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT I HAVE --
BEEN PRIVILEGED TO BENEFIT FROM
A MISS BUZZERS EXTRAORDINARY
WORK FOR NOW GOING ON SEVEN
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN IN THIS
FINE INSTITUTION I THINK --
THE GOVERNORS OF APPOINTMENT OF
SPONSORS DIRECTOR FINANCES AN
EXCEPTIONAL ONE AND I LOOK
FORWARD --
TO VOTING I AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CONGRATULATIONS.
THAT'S QUITE A STATEMENT MISTER
SENATOR ROTH IRA.
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
I LIKE THE DITTO THE COMMENTS
MADE.
BY.
AND I REALLY REALLY ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY.
AND AND I I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT
THE NEW GOVERNOR IS GOING TO AT
LEAST FISCALLY MERE A LOT OF
WHAT THE THE OLD GOVERNOR DID
WHICH I THINK IS BENEFIT
BENEFITTED OUR STATE AND YOU
SHARED.
THE BALANCING ACT THAT YOU HAVE
TO DO AND I THINK THEY YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT FULLY AND THEN
YOU'RE GOING TO IMPLEMENT THE
THE WILL OF THE GOVERNOR AND THE
PEOPLE THE CALIFORNIA SO I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO CASTING AN
AYE VOTE AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I SENATOR BATES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO JUST THIS MORNING INTERVIEW.
INTERVIEW MISS OF AUTHOR OF A
NEW MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE AND
I THINK MOST OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT.
I ASK PERHAPS HAD BEEN ASKED
BEFORE AND NOW SHE HAD EXCELLENT
ANSWERS ON MY CONCERN IS MAN.
REALLY FOCUSED ON THE DMV AUDIT
AND SHE'S PICK THAT UP AND I WAS
VERY VERY PLEASED WITH.
THE DEPTH OF THE ANSWERS THAT
SHE WAS LOOKING OUT
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COME
THROUGH THAT ON IT I DID HAVE
ONE QUESTION I DIDN'T ANSWER AND
I THINK YOU MIGHT MAY HAVE
ANSWERED IT TOOK YOU LEAVE THAT.
THE ME REPEATED AGAIN IT'S WHAT
A PLAN YOU HAVE ON GOING FORWARD
SO WE IDENTIFY MAYBE PRO
ACTIVELY SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE WITH OUR AGENCIES
AND THEIR FIVE THEIR OPERATION
AND THERE FISCAL.
ARE REPORTING --
I SAY THAT BECAUSE WHEN I WAS A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
THE ARTISTS THAT WE GOT ACTUALLY
ANTICIPATED.
THE PROBLEMS AND PUT INTO THE
REPORT HOW WE WOULD ADDRESS
THOSE GOING FORWARD AND IT WAS
CERTAINLY BY YEAR I MEAN YOU
CAN'T GET IT ALL DONE.
IN THE FIRST FIVE MONTHS SO ARE
WE GOING TO HAVE A SYSTEM AS WE
LOOK AT SOME OF THESE AGENCIES
IN PARTICULAR.
DIEM BE AND HOW WE'RE
STRUCTURING OTHER REMEDIES THAT
NEED TO BE MADE AND HE AND
SEVERAL AREAS MOST IMPORTANTLY
ARE.
UNFORTUNATELY WITH GOVERNMENT WE
ALWAYS HAVE THESE I. T. PROBLEMS
SO JUST A QUICK CALL COMMENT ON
THAT AND YOU KNOW THEN YOU
ALREADY HAVE MY I BUILT ONE WEEK
WHEN THEY CALL BUT I THOUGHT IT
WE SHOULD HAVE THAT ON THE
RECORD SO I HAVE IT.
FROM MY NOTES YEAH I MEAN SUCH A
GOOD CRY PRESS ON ALL OF OUR
STAFF IS THAT THEY ARE OUT
TALKING TO PART TO DO TO
DEPARTMENTS AND IDENTIFIED
ISSUES.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO RAISE
THOSE UP AND THOSE CAN COME IN
FROM ALL DIFFERENT CHANNELS THEY
CAN COME IN FROM THE LEGISLATURE
THAT CAN COME IN FROM.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THEY CAN
BE RAISED --
THROUGH AN AUDIT --
YOU KNOW THESE ARE ALL THINGS
THAT WE SHOULD AND WE WE ARE
LOOKING AT IN ORDER TO GET AHEAD
OF PROBLEMS.
I'M WE DO HAVE A RESEARCH
ANALYSIS UNIT THAT DOES --
TACKLE SOME OF THESE IDENTIFIED
PROBLEMS AND REALLY AND DOES A
MORE THOROUGH AB --
ANALYSIS OF WHAT.
ARE THE SYMPTOMS OF THE PROBLEM
BUT BUT WHAT ARE THE
UNDERPINNINGS OF THE PROBLEM BUT
THEN ALSO HOW DO WE ADDRESS THE
ISSUE.
AND THAT'S I'M AT A PART OF MY
DEPARTMENT THAT I DEFINITELY
WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT --
BECAUSE THEY DO REALLY IMPORTANT
WORK ON ON THOSE --
ISSUES THAT WE DON'T ALWAYS HAVE
THE TIME AND THE STAFF RESOURCES
AT TO TAKE THE MORE IN DEPTH
LOOK AT AM I ALSO AM OVERSEE AND
THE AUDIT AND EVALUATION
DIVISION AND THEY ALSO CAN BE A
RESOURCE ON TO HELP.
ADD TO ADDRESS AND GET OUT SOME
OF THESE MORE I SYSTEMIC ISSUES
THAT THAT NEED TO BE SOLVED SO I
I PROBLEM SOLVING IT'S PART OF
OUR CORE VALUES THAT FINANCE.
AND IT'S ONE THAT I REALLY WANT
TO EMPHASIZE A LOT.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
NECESSARILY ABOUT.
ABOUT HOLDING THE LINE ON
SPENDING BUT IT'S ALSO IT'S ALSO
ABOUT I'M REALLY LOOKING AT WHAT
THE ISSUES ARE AND SOMETIMES
THAT DOES REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND THAT'S OKAY WHEN
WE'RE SOLVING A PROBLEM FOR THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I THE VERY GENERAL
ANSWER BUT IT'S IT'S IT'S
SOMETHING.
WHEREI'M AT EACH AND EVERY DAY
I HAVEN'T THE FOCUS OF OF OUR
STAFF?
THANK YOU FOR READING CONCERNING
ZACHARY THE WHAT I EXPECTED.
GOOD JOB THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS BATES MR MINING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN.
THANK YOU MS BLASTER
CONGRATULATIONS ON THIS
APPOINTMENT WE'VE HAD THE HONOR
OF SERVING TOGETHER AND DISTINCT
CAPACITIES THE THE TOUGHEST ONE
I THINK WAS STARTING OUT DURING
THE RECESSION IN 200-082-0009
WHEN STATE LOST ABOUT THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUE.
NEW ALWAYS MAINTAINED A SENSE OF
CONFIDENCE AS WE NAVIGATED
THROUGH AN I GOT THAT SAME
SENSITIVE.
CONFIDENCE YESTERDAY WHEN WE
SPOKE -- A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS I THINK --
WORTHWHILE FOR FOR THE COMEDIAN
AND FOR THE PUBLIC --
MANY BELIEVE WE'RE HEADED
TOWARDS A DAY FOR A DROP NOT A
QUESTION OF WHETHER THE QUINN.
ON HOW DO YOU WANT HOW DO YOU
SLEEP AT NIGHT NOW --
HOW DO WE FORECAST HOW DO WE
PREPARE AND?
WHAT'S YOUR SENSE OF CONFIDENCE
ABOUT OUR ABILITY.
TO WHETHER THAT DIP OR THAT
DROPPED IN THE FUTURE.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING TOWARDS I'D
AT M. BEING ABLE TO RESPOND IN A
BETTER WAY THAN THE LAST TIME WE
WORKED ON THE ON THIS ISSUE
BEFORE BY BY SETTING UP A RAINY
DAY FUND AND CONTINUING TO PUT
MONEY.
INTO THAT FIND AT THE THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WAS FRONT AND CENTER
WHEN WE WERE BUILDING THE BUDGET
WITH THE GOVERNOR --
IS THE LACK AT THE TIME HI AND
THAT'S BECAUSE WE ARE ALMOST TEN
YEARS AND TO THE CURRENT.
FISCAL EXPANSION THAT'S THAT'S A
RECORD ANTICIPATING THAT THERE
WILL BE AT SOME POINT A SLOW
DOWN AND AND AND WE FORECASTED
EVEN MILD RECESSION COULD
RESULTS AND A SEVENTY BILLION
DOLLAR DROP IN REVENUES OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIOD SO THAT'S A
DAUNTING NUMBER.
ABSOLUTELY --
BUT THAT'S ALSO WHY WE'VE MADE A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET IN WHAT WE CALL
BUDGET RESILIENCY IN THIS IS
THAT IT'S A COMBINATION.
OF OF SEVERAL FACTORS ONE IS
CONTINUING TO BUILD RESERVES
HAVING THOSE RESERVES THAT ARE
SATISFIED IN THE RAINY DAY FUND --
FOR EXACTLY AT THAT AN ECONOMIC
SLOWDOWN IT'S NOT OUR OPERATING
EMERGENCY RESERVES THAT SET
ASIDE FOR WHEN WE ACTUALLY ARE
GOING TO NEED NEEDED.
I'M AND THEN ALSO PAIN
CONTINUING TO PAY DOWN DEBTS AND
DEFERRALS SOME OF WHICH WERE
TAKEN OUT MANY YEARS AGO.
AND THAT IS ALL GOING TO HELP US
I'M TO WHETHER ADD THAT THE
VOLATILITY THAT DOES EXIST IN
OUR REVENUE SYSTEM.
I AND ALSO JUST THE
CORRESPONDING --
YOU KNOW I HAVE REQUIREMENTS
THAT WE HAVE ON THE EXPENDITURE
SIDE BOTH PROPOSITION --
NINETY EIGHT BUT ALSO MANY OF
OUR OTHER ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS
THAT DURING ECONOMIC SLOWDOWN
SOMETIMES GROW AND NOT
APPROPRIATE WHEN PEOPLE ARE
LOSING THEIR JOBS AND AND NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
I'M SO THE COMBINATION OF THOSE
TWO THINGS DOES MAKE MANAGING
THE STATE'S FISCAL.
I'M BALANCE THE A VERY VERY --
AND IT'S AND IT'S VERY FRAGILE --
THE STATE'S BALANCE AND SO I'M
I'M VERY GROUNDED AND THAT THOSE
BAD YEARS THOSE RECESSION YEARS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WERE MAKING
CHOICES THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
SUSTAIN A OVER THE LONG RUN.
THANK YOU --
AND I GUESS I WOULD JUST ASK --
IN OUR COMMUNICATION BETWEEN.
YOUR AGENT SEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE --
ANY EARLY WARNINGS OF CONCERN
THE MORE OF US THAT CAN WITHOUT
[inaudible]
WITHOUT.
CREATING UNNECESSARY PANIC JUST --
ANY TRANS --
TENDENCIES WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR
US TO KNOW THAT WELL.
YES AND WE WILL BE UPDATING OUR
FORECAST FOR THE MAY REVISION
WHICH IS WE DO THE TWO TIMES A
YEAR AND THAT'S A IT'S REALLY
GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT WHAT
HAPPENS IN APRIL THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT WE WILL BE REALLY LOOKING
AT CLEARLY --
IS ALL OF THE THE REVENUE
INFORMATION COMING IN APRIL BUT
ALSO THE BROADER ECONOMIC.
INDICATORS IN THE ECONOMY --
ALSO WITH --
KEY AND WHERE WE ARE MONITORING
THOSE ON A WEEKLY BASIS THANK
YOU AND THEN MADAM CHAIR JUST MY
FINALLY REALLY A COMMENT --
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY KNOW HOW
MANY BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS USE
IT ON A NEAR CAPACITY.
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
COMMISSION STATE MANDATES POOLED
MONEY INVESTMENT BOARD PUBLIC
WORKS BOARD STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM STATE
ALLOCATION BOARD.
IN STATE LANDS COMMISSION WE
TALKED SOME ABOUT.
THAT ROLE IN THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION YOU SERVE WITH THE
STATE COMPTROLLER IN THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
IN MY DISTRICT. TWO HUNDRED
MILES OF COASTLINE INCLUDING THE
CURRENT SIDE OF DIABLO CANYON
NUCLEAR FACILITY THAT HAS
ANNOUNCED ITS PATH TO
DECOMMISSIONING --
AND I WOULD JUST.
ASK THE AS A MEMBER THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION --
THAT THAT STAY ON ON YOUR RADAR
IN THE RADAR OF THE COMMISSION --
IN TERMS OF PUBLIC SAFETY FIRST --
IN POTENTIAL FUTURE USES THE
BENEFIT.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
THANK YOU --
AND WE'RE GONNA TURN --
TO PEOPLE HER WHO ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION BUT
BEFORE WE DO I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MEET YESTERDAY.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER MINING IN
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THIS PUBLIC
HEARING AND WE'VE HAD OUR
OPPORTUNITIES TO MEET.
I ALSO THINK WE HAVE --
VAST EXPERIENCE ALREADY WORKING.
WITH YOU AND I'M PLEASED TO SEE --
THE APPOINTMENT COME FORWARD WE
APPRECIATE THE WAY IN WHICH YOU
HAVE WORKED WITH THE LEGISLATURE
YOUR AVAILABILITY TO US.
ON ANY NUMBER OF ISSUES AND THE
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT --
TREND CONTINUING --
I DID MENTION AND AND WILL AGAIN
JUST FOR THE RECORD.
THE DESIRE THAT WE FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO WORK ON A BUDGET SCHEDULE
BETWEEN THE MAY REVISION AND THE
AND THE THE DEADLINE --
THAT WORKS AND HELPS LATER DO
THE BUDGET PROCESS.
NOT IN A COMPACTED TIME BUT I
KNOW YOU'RE AWARE OF THAT AND
DOC.
I THINK WE ARE WELL SERVED --
BY THE EXPERIENCE OF COURSE THAT
YOU BRING.
I AT THIS POINT IN TIME --
IT IS JUST IT'S JUST GOOD TO SEE
THAT WE HAVE ON HAVE YOU
CONTINUING IN THIS ROLE.
OUR WITH OUR NEW GOVERNOR.
ARMED.
WITH THAT --
SO I ASK ALL MY QUESTIONS AND I
APPRECIATE THE TIME YOU GAVE ME
YESTERDAY.
I WANTED I ASKED THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE AND
WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD IN
SUPPORT.
OF MS FOSLER.
PLEASE YOU CAN ACTUALLY USE THE
MIKE OVER THERE IF YOU DON'T
MIND GIVING US YOUR NAME AND
JEFF MEAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE NOMINATION OF MS BASEL
OUR COURSE.
THE COUNTIES ARE SO INTERTWINED
PROVIDING SO MANY OF THE STATE
SERVICES AND AND IN HER TIM AT
AT FINANCE SHE IS ALWAYS.
WHO HERSELF TO BE OPEN --
TO TALKING WITH US ABOUT ALL OF
THE MANY ISSUES THAT MATTER SO
MUCH -- TO
BOTH THE STATE AND COUNTY SO
WANTED TO COME IN AND SUPPORTER
TODAY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
WELL THERE'S A FAMILIAR FACE
STANDING UP YEAH.
THEN YOU WERE JUST LETTING HIM.
FOR THE RECORD I THINK YOU'VE
ALREADY OUT MICHAEL COME WHEN
FORMER DIRECTOR OF FINANCE I
THINK YOU'VE ALREADY FIGURED OUT
HOW SPECIAL LIKE YOU.
REALLY ISN'T JUST FOR THE RECORD
SHE HAS ALL THE SKILLS AND
ABILITIES THAT YOU WOULD WANT IN
THIS POSITION SO --
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY AND HAPPY
TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER COHEN LET THE
RECORD REFLECT CAST I STRONG ARM
THE FORMER.
YOUR FINANCE TO COME FORWARD --
IT'S GREAT TO SEE ALL OF YOU
HERE TODAY --
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M HAPPY TO
DO SO MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL.
SENATORS BATES.
BATES AYE MONNING.
MONNING HI ROB.
ROTH I WILL.
WILK AYE AT FIVE THAT IS
UNANIMOUS RESPONSE OUR
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK.
NOW THE REAL FUN BEGINS --
WE WILL GO TO EXECUTIVE SESSION --
I WILL WAIT.
ON FOLKS TO LEAVE